really that's a mic check dummy that's
none of my track your animal I watched a
lot of David Attenborough on the plane I
bet you did you want to start you wants
to know you started you're listening to
the dollop on the all things comedy
Network this is a bilingual American
history podcast you need to learn
another language if you're gonna do it
each week I read a story from American
history your name is David Anthony - my
friend Gareth Reynolds who has no idea
what the topic is going to be about my
dress and then
intro and call this quote is jam-packed
Jim I'm the [ __ ] guy Dave okay names
Garrity but it's good is it four five
and this is not gonna come particularly
now hit him with the puppy you both
resent sick arguments
we're live step it up have your morning
voice on how we're live how do you how
do I turn him so I can't hear him how do
I turn him down I think I might have to
leave so uh we have a new show announced
Chicago on December 1st bingo bingo you
know tickets are now on sale go to the
Dolph on tor.com
tour schedule we got other cities Boise
Salt Lake City Denver Minneapolis two
shows Nashville of Madison Cleveland
Pittsburgh Boston Royal Oak Michigan
which I don't think his actual place but
we'll find out I can't wait to meet the
king yeah I don't think that's I shall
bow before him
Royal Oak your majesty so for our first
podcast backers we represent
Los Angeles the kingdom of dolla path
you're back we are brought to you by
Brooke linen Gareth you enjoy sleeping
right I am a big fan of sleep okay so
loving it's like oh like a thirty-year
life right sleeping uh yeah I think of
anyone's life but yeah mine for sure I
am for that it's a wooden you want
really good sheets if you were gonna
sleep for 30 your life yeah for sure
unless you were sleeping on stones or
something yeah I would rather have my
sheets on the stones
absolutely up that's that's what Brooke
linen is they're the best most
comfortable sheep no big markup is a
sheep's you guys think sheeps I want to
be clear not sheep they're not offering
they are not sheep they were started in
April 2004 but husband husband wife Jean
because they were looking around they're
like why she's so expensive that we
can't we can't we cut out the middleman
and get this done so they said I
definitely came from an argument yeah
they were screaming at each other so
there's no like markups fees nothing
like that you can save as much as three
hundred percent on these sheets and I
use them and I also use them and also
love them yeah great ones right yeah
weird
yeah I'm a white I'm a white sheet go
let's go white now here we go I got ya
we go
my Brooklands are white yeah they were
considered they were the winner of the
best online bedding category and Good
Housekeeping which I know you love as I
attended the awards last year as a
presenter for Best pillowcase so this is
what I'm saying again luxury sheets
super underpriced you got to try them
Brooklyn and cheats are the best most
comfortable sheets I slept on Brooklyn
calm has an exclusive offer for just our
dollop listeners get $20 off and free
shipping when you use promo code the
dollop at Brooklyn and Comm Brooklyn
linen is so confident that they offer a
risk-free 60 date night satisfaction
guarantee and a lifetime warranty on all
of their sheets and comforters the only
way to get $20 off and free shipping is
to use promo code the dalek at Brooklyn
and dot-com that's Brooke linen BR ook
li n e and calm promo code the dollop
these are the best sheets ever Brooke
linen we give a sheet I'll see myself
out of it now we're also sponsored by
our X bar which you were already a huge
consumer of yes or no still remain to be
they came on board yes
simple ingredients everything's good
filling they're good they're good trap
that's a good travel snack yeah is also
good in-betweener I use them when I hike
because I hug him back up to the top of
the San Gabriels and then I break out
and reward yourself with our X bar
blueberry blueberry is great yeah every
one of them has listed ingredients right
on the front it's like dates like they
tell you like whites like some peanuts
and some of that stuff on the front it's
not it's not a surprise bar no BS no are
X bar core ingredients do all the
talking
it's simply like eating three egg whites
two dates and six almonds with no BS
that's what you just said okay whether
you like it sweet or savory chocolate or
fruit flavors then there's an R X bar
for you particularly for Gareth yeah our
X bars come at 11 two different flavor
and varieties they're gluten free soy
free and dairy free with no added sugar
no artificial colors no artificial
flavors preservatives or fillers rx bars
are great for breakfast on the go a
snack at
the office throwing in your bag when you
go on a plane in your backpack bike ride
or a hike hike who said hike we're just
gonna get a football snap today you're
not careful or pre or post-workout snack
yeah we love my you start giving them to
Aaron for free so there what's your
favorite one I like blueberry which I
like peanut butter mmm
so for 25% off your first office visit
our X bar dot com slash dollop and then
a proed promo code dollop at checkout
that's our X bar comm slash dollop and
code dollop for 25% off your first order
man I I should be taking advantage of
this yeah you're they should put brain
stuff in the RX Mercer
Dave I've got a few new dates to throw
at you I'll be at the Tempe improv May
31st through June 2nd you can go on
their website and there's a promo code
which is dollop and you get $10 tickets
on all of the shows and then the third
and then June 21st through 23rd I'll be
at the stress factory in New Jersey and
then Laughs comedy club in Seattle June
29th and 30th I'll be there Hey
Dave's showboating for some reason nope
don't have time to get it together we
were gone for a week because uh you know
stuff happened I'm fine I don't know if
you want to talk at all I know I know a
lot of times when people talk about the
podcast they talk about how they love
the banter before the show from the
Harvard Crimson where the gentlemen very
effusive about his praise for our
commercial work and our banter pre-show
yeah he really likes it when we give
dates and do commercials he'd he
preferred that happen at the end where
he doesn't have to have to listen and we
prefer people to go to things yeah yeah
April 5th 1839 your bar Lord everything
seems to be the year's Christ okay
Robert smalls was born a slave on Ash
Dale plantation on Lady's Island South
Carolina what a lot to digest here
already here
ladies Island uh-huh and that is a fox
show yeah ladies a function okay yeah so
the makers of Cougar Town ladies Island
so the way it works is there are 12
women drop on an island how Betty I have
to kill each other oh my god watch the
last one out gets a dress is there a
host it's a good job yeah
Hey look amazing his mother Lydia polite
what's Dave what happened yeah a lot
happened his mom's Lydia polite yeah
okay she was 43 and she was a house
slave okay
house slaves had a better life than
field slaves obviously yes sure we've
all seen in the films yeah many were
taught to read and write
sure house slaves anyway the children
know how slaves are often raised
alongside their masters white children
okay
right female slaves served as nannies
right yep it's like a family affair sort
of thing except for the family's worst
exactly and for the families forced to
be in the family yeah yeah with Robert
smalls Roberts mo who his father as it's
a little murky we're not really sure who
was father
you mean Richard impolite no that's not
a there no one it is believed his
mother's owner Henry McKee was Roberts
father okay gotcha
we some people would call that rape ya
know and strong history of it too yeah
others think of founding fathers yeah
big fan big fans
others think Henry McKee's father John
McKee was Robert's father so either the
owner or the owners dad was there a
Maury island we should get them on that
there was also Patrick smalls okay who
was a white manager on the plantation
and people thought that
he might be the father his last name
obviously matches but one smalls
Bogg Rafiq included the name smalls was
given to Robert because he was short
okay and not because he was the I mean
it's a nail in the coffin for the smalls
guy yeah I mean yeah Ken Burns can do a
whole documentary about this and is that
just what we're in like the Dick Tracy
naming phase we're just we're just yeah
enslavement that's fun but his father
was definitely white because Robert
smalls had quote distinct mulatto
features cool terms welcome back to cool
terms cool terms that are fired to use
Henry McKee treated Robert like a son in
some ways except he didn't teach him how
to read or write right so in like sudden
couple ways son in the way that you
don't beat him maybe or write you let
him sleep inside like share kind of ways
right good father stuff the Maki's had
four kids although one died to five
another one at two no way did and he
ended up having ten so at this time I
think they had four but either way it's
not something that we can joke about or
laugh about period okay it's a fact yeah
not funny no let's leave it there
mmm-hmm no fun this is the first time
I've ever read of kids dying Dave story
Dave not okay to talk about okay
it happened sure yeah but we're not here
to make light of it no this is
straight-up
information this is we are going back to
the original version of the dollop where
it's just you in a garage shouting to
yourself it's time to cut me out
according to some person Robert spent a
lot of time at the McKee house and was
friends with the McKee children and
their white friends sure and like many
local slaves in the area Robert had a
love for water because it's right there
on the water right I'm consumed by
staying hydrated know him like water
like right he like water fun and like
the swimming and it sure I get it I was
a kid well you enjoyed boats and ships
when he's a kid he would run down the
docks with the other children when they
heard
passing steam ships whistling okay
that's a good time that is a great time
and if you've ever been a child but
that's that's really something that's
where you wanna be
now what yeah that's it that's the day
I'm exhausted okay let's go back to me
owning you oh boy
I think I know why I look forward to the
steamships because of their house slave
lives his mom thought that Robert wasn't
getting the real gist of what slave life
was like in a bad way um she's like sure
you don't have the understanding you
need to have well she was like you
should know what this is really like
sure because there's a reality out there
you might get hit in the face with
special so when he was 10 she took him
to see a slave auction and a whipping
post where slaves were beaten just a
little field trip it's a good field trip
if you're a kid I mean you know even
it's it's dark yep
it's also believed she took him to the
fields to work as a field hand picking
cotton rice and tobacco and sleeping on
steamship let's go let's all what why
but there's a steamship whistle add to
the steamship let's go with the
steamship guys
so his oddly his view of slave life
changed pretty abruptly from that
experience yeah it's weird
we had yeah how were his white friends
at that point to him years ago
future enemies so suddenly is not really
into being a slave Cheryl nice yeah not
down so when he was 12
Roberts mother convinced McKee to send
him to Charleston to learn a trade
because she didn't want him to become
some beaten and overworked field slave
like if you could get a job have a thing
to do then you wouldn't have to live
that life okay well I mean or except for
the ownership part right at this point
Robert started to speak out against
slavery and challenging local laws which
kept getting him arrested right it's
illegal to question yeah yeah you
question an ownership get in this place
where we own you temporarily that's not
yeah I guess it doesn't only make that
no so Henry McKee would bail him out of
jail
time right old dad okay kind of done his
mom started to feel first fear for his
safety because he's getting a little
yeah right you know yeah
yapping yeah she should have never taken
him out into the real world that's right
so in 1851 McKee sent Roberts Charleston
he lived in one of the Maki's homes
there and worked as a busboy
at a hotel okay he made five dollars a
week which was all sent him a key
sure sure that's that's good stuff nice
good daddy
you see how that works is a really good
profit situation for the owner yeah yeah
for sure well to be fair though has the
owner gotten enough it's time to worry
about his bottom when that's true okay
that's our hero obviously yeah that's
he's definitely our hero in this so he
took a second job as a street lamp
lighter mm-hmm um different times that
job got hurt real bad
Electric accomplished by electricity as
did we're bringing back lamplighters
we're all gonna be lighting lamps again
take my hand the new economy there's
also the guy that would go around and
knock on windows with a big stick to it
people I got [ __ ] my arm twice and
just like no no snooze with that guy
could you come back in seven minutes you
won't be sleeping anymore but I would
just really I just want to lay with my
LA with my eyes closed
awake and ruin my morning a little slow
I want okay do you come back in three I
just came back just give me three what
is your plan I could cut it in half I
have other windows to wrap I know I know
but I'm just I just a couple more
minutes and I know what just looked at
but I shouldn't have it yeah you get a
wrist do I have it I might have it you
might know another wrist watch maybe a
pocket watch oh that's what it is I
don't know if they were smart if you put
it on the wrist yet no no [ __ ] idiots
so he negotiated with McKee to keep some
extra money from the lamp lining job
what a great negotiation yeah you mean
keep the money that you've earned yeah
I'm listening he hired himself out for
various jobs the docks and on ships and
he finally eventually became a sailor
and then worked his way up to wheelman
whoa
if he had been white he would have been
called a pilot but since he was black he
was called a wheelman can't let can't
let and can't let people use the same
term now it is funny it is amazing that
like white people were like we're a
little sensitive about our terms yeah
let's not we don't love it when people
use our terms against our will I'm a
pilot so you're not upon any way we'll
say whatever we want Drive go wheelman
as a wheelman Robert became an expert at
navigating in the local waterways around
Charleston there he was respected and
moved into leadership roles his
background made him feel at ease talking
to people from all different walks of
life okay I think it's probably a little
bit rare at this time yeah
in 1856 at 17 years old Robert fell for
a 31 year old hotel maid named Hannah
Jones okay bring more towels
no maybe clean the cups in the bathroom
no yeah I don't know he's trying to
these are things he's saying like you
need you to come in here and make sure
the pen works to check the second drawer
for the Bible baby over there Wow
Hannah had two daughters 12 and 14 so
he's three years older they call me Dad
he might want to date the 14 year old
baby but because this just seems
or anyone your own yeah almost twice
that's fine that's a normal situation
for everything yeah it's all good I feel
like a sitcom was coming to well but
because they were slaves they couldn't
legally enter it into a contract which
meant they had to ask their owners to
let them marry
it's just cool that's a cool thing
because like you know if you this proper
thing you're supposed to do is if you
marry when we were supposed to ask your
parents like you know I would like your
daughter yeah but instead you ask this
time you gotta go hey man you own me so
can I marry this person I love Oh what
you want to get married do you I love
your well holder she's me nothing sorry
I got distracted what what are you
asking Anna's hand what do you mean a
lot more I mean listen to me wheelman
yeah you may take her hand but you take
nothing else I will shut this down take
all that [ __ ] I like your style wheelman
I like your style
go get her have fun thank you but if you
have a lot of kids and one dies we won't
make light of it okay is that it's not
okay right so the owners let them marry
a slave couples work oh great really
great of the owners the cool thing is
having progressive slave owners she's
nice yeah they weren't usually allowed
to live together one slave sure if
they're I assume if they're owned by the
same guy they could because they would
be on the same property but they're
owned by different owners then it's
complicated it's complicated
and that's gonna be the name this had
come it's complicated it's complicated
we got one guy was errant it'll be Randy
Newman he's the complicated feed zone is
a complicated marriage Anita dokey he's
a complicated so uh their owners
Hanazono was named Sam Samuel Kingman
and his owner McKee they allowed them to
get married and live together as man and
wife completely separate from their
owners because they both have jobs so
they're like just keep the money coming
in you guys can do whatever you want
right okay so but that was a thing where
you would sort of like if slave was
working then you would get their income
and that was just like a better
situation than having to go sort of work
the property in a way I guess so I mean
it all sounds pretty [ __ ] it's totally
[ __ ] but I would say that out of those
situations yeah I mean again it's two
piles of [ __ ] but that's him oh wow
really neck where was at an all-time
crazy I think the one thing racist could
unite on was that the things you're
putting around our collars bizarre and
not helpful it's it's almost clowny and
then she is here okay obviously pictures
not as good of her because yeah it looks
like they put a filter on it but you
know he got he got he's super into that
sure yeah so uh so so he now he two
years later they have a daughter named
Elizabeth smalls and now he's worried
the owner could sell away his wife and
kid right that's a that's a weird thing
we don't have as much today when you get
married but back then if you're slaving
got married
your wife's owner could sell because
whatever came out of her he owns oh my
god so he can sell your kid and your
wife away what just because he's like I
need some extra cash or whatever you
know around funny money music I'm gonna
get some blow instead I keep totally
frank whatever you know so Robert talked
to Hannah zone or Kingman and he agreed
to sell his Robert his own wife and
daughter to him for eight hundred
dollars he the owner of Hanna agreed to
sell Robert
Hannah and the daughter for 800 ah yeah
he could buy his own daughter by his
wife what a pretty great again another
sweetheart deal yeah thanks
he starts saving and Roberts deal with
McKee he was able to keep about $15 a
month after all is said and done okay so
he's three years away yeah it's not
great now in 1860 Lincoln was elected
Abraham Lincoln
yeah the weird yeah weird beard that's
the guy the guy who had no idea what he
was doing with his head yeah okay yeah
the good people of South Carolina were
furious because they he didn't want them
to own people and they were super into
that like that's part of their Jam yeah
and on December 20 1860 South Carolina
became the first state to secede from
the union
okay so we'll see them later yeah off
they go
[Laughter]
so we on here South Carolina's secession
declarations sure quote a geographical
line has been drawn across the Union and
all the states north of that line have
united in the election of a man to the
high office of president whose opinions
and purposes are hostile to slavery so
but that kind of puts a dent in the
whole slate state rights argument so it
turns out pretty much about slavery so
actually it is about states rights
because the South didn't want the north
to have free black people so that states
right part yeah but I I think your point
is fair yeah so Robert was hired to
pilot the steamer planter you mean wheel
minute Willman let's not go throwing
around terms he hasn't earned yet he's
not a white Dave he's not a pilot that
was bad of me actually that'll be a
great it's complicated plot that'll be
great
where did they rob is going to become a
pilot that's the planter right there
okay was he whistling the whole time he
was will many always whistled so he he
quickly becomes respected and trusted on
board there's a few slaves on the
planter
on April 12 1861 the Civil War kicked
off a Jew lations everybody right in
South Carolina right in Charleston more
Confederate forces fired on Fort Sumter
which was octopi occupied by Union
soldiers so they kick it off and they go
there's a fort in our stuff the fort is
bombarded Charleston's rich white
residents came out to watch quote a
splendid pyrotechnic exhibition so they
all got up on the roofs and they watched
the bombing out so this is pretty tiring
yeah prefab works but I'm they watch the
attack of look at out there that's fun
to watch unit she pretty
the Confederates they tried them they
chartered the planter like they charted
the news for summer they charted they
charted it and they started using it to
haul supplies okay
including ammunition guns we were doing
that the Confederates okay so in and out
of Charleston Harbor right so so you get
so Robert is is essentially and these
other slaves on the ship are essentially
working to keep themselves slaves mm-hmm
hard to keep the energy up for that job
yeah talk about you talk about trying to
keep this ship morale up yeah that's a
hard one come on boys otherwise these
flames to get free present company
excluded not want to offend you Robert
you know I've always found you to be a
terrific wheelman can't have you out
there pilot and making your own money
imagine what a world that Lincoln he's
been to stove top top weird track a beer
after that that's right so when there
was a three pack that I'm good
one day while the captain was not on the
boat a slave crewman put the cap in
straw hat on Roberts head and said quote
boy you look just like the captain of
that comment stuck with Robert a Union
Navy blockade was put in place to stop
Confederate states from trading so they
put ships out there blocked off the
ports sure major southern ports were
blocked including Charleston
it's really hurt the economy of the
south and they couldn't make profits and
they started starving no no it's not the
Confederacy tried to use torpedoes on
the blockade but that didn't work what
yeah so they don't have watches for
their wrists but they have torpedoes no
fireworks but I guarantee you some guys
they had watches man yeah you know I
thought your podcast I thought that you
were really on top of history I don't
think it's fun to make fun of the watch
technology back then they were doing
pretty good my dad died way making a
watch okay my name is Teddy pocket watch
a little offended by your last podcast
straight straight up offended like
directly at me like you're talking to me
the Confederacy so they're [ __ ] the
blockade successful there they're not
doing on today and November 1861 Union
troops took Port Royal which is about 60
miles
I think it's south of Charleston I
believe it is so yeah so all the
southern whites
fled they just [ __ ] bailed but the
slaves didn't they're like oh this is
really good so by March Roberts mother
is now how great does it have to feel
when whites are fleeing ah you're just
like oh my god what yeah that's like
more of whatever is happening normally
like like what's a Bambi like when you
ever see things fleeing you're supposed
to be scared but when whites are fleeing
I think it's okay when whites are
fleeing you're like stick around I think
some good changes happening if animals
run to the higher level run with them if
whites run just stick around because
something good might be coming so uh so
the slave stayed by March Roberts mother
was living free in Beaufort engaged to
cook let's just be I mean you know and
is obviously a dark ass awful time this
has I feel pretty good yeah pretty
[ __ ] great so Robert thought living
as a free man in Beaufort sounded pretty
pretty good better much better than
shipping guns to people who wanted to
keep him a slave that was a conflicting
super by 1862 he had saved seven
hundred of the eight hundred dollars to
buy Hannah and Elizabeth how many years
are we talking here but it's like three
I think okay it's a little bit sure
but then the end of the kid Roberts most
junior so now no but sometimes I call
them Beauregard nicknames were weird
though regards always it's always been a
winner yeah we want to keep it short so
you but you I don't know if you're if
you're Robert here you would brought it
would be better to hold off on another
kid right cuz then you get the wife of
the kid right and then you can have as
many kids but you're super in a bounine
yeah hey she's a hot 31 year old lady
you get it we're both like 16 year old
dudes we say that yeah i Nino I want one
too yeah and I need it yeah so now he
doesn't know what the price is gonna be
right what cause inflation he didn't he
doesn't go he doesn't go back to the
owner but he's now he's like worried
well the price is gonna go up because I
had a kid which is a cool a cool thing
to think of like a for sure that's how
you want to plan a family that's what
they mean when they say family planning
yeah how much will it have cost you to
buy your kids by April 1862 a barge man
buy in April sorry in April 1862 a barge
man by slaves was sailed out to the
Union fleet and turned over so in
Charleston there's a barge and these
slaves are working on they're like well
we just take this to the blockade so
they just sailed what now hold on a
minute it looks like they headed out to
that blockade oh I'm starting to think
we shouldn't have just left all the
slaves on the barge oh man they start to
think for themselves like we fear they
become an independent thinkers yeah so
so this wasn't a huge event but
definitely a black eye sort of to the
south they're great yeah Robert small
kept up appearances and attacked the
thieves on the barge as quote the
meanest of mortals he attacked the
thieves on the via the guys who stole
the barge oh he called it hey so he's
playing a game Wow any game sure a
fellow slave crewman jokingly said they
should steal the planter
and Robert said that actually wasn't a
joke and he cautiously checked with the
other slaves in the crew if they wanted
to steal the planter mutiny except for
one guy one slave he didn't trust okay
so how [ __ ] up as a slave do you have
to be that other slaves like hey might
you want to get out of here yeah and
you're so damaged that you're like yeah
that's the environment you get created
when you have total sin here no talking
to that guy the rest of the crew starts
meeting at Roberts house to come up with
a plan okay
Robert then told Hannah and said they
would probably be executed on the spot
if they were caught and Hannah said
quote it is a risk dear but you and I
and our little ones must be free I will
go for where you die I will die I get it
yeah get it yep
the planner then went on a two-week trip
and came back with four large guns from
forts that were being dismantled in
Charleston the crew loaded 200 pounds of
ammunition and more guns on so there's
just like they really do not see this
coming
there's a shitload of guns on that yeah
that ship load ship load sorry no need
to cuss my [ __ ]
so it's supposed to leave the next
morning and take the guns and amination
to you know a bunch of guys supposed to
is interesting yeah the planner was
moored at the wharf in front of general
Ripley's headquarters believe it or not
he was in charge of the planter and had
been in charge of the bars that was
stolen oh boy he's having a bad run yeah
well yeah that there is oh there we go
the Ripper look at that there's no mouth
there it's just all hair I'm aiming for
that turret so 20 guards were posted at
the wharf that evening okay some just a
few paces from the boat the ship was are
you looking at your beard right now I'm
comparing my beard to this gentleman
horrible ooze my mouth is the worst
thing that's ever been said yeah so
there's there's all these guards just to
some a few paces from the ship the ship
is scheduled to head out in the morning
so three white officers Charles ray Lee
Samuel Hancock and Samuel pitcher
we're supposed to stay on board
overnight okay especially cuz the barges
been stolen right hey white guys let's
let's have some white guys on the boat
mom ladies that's all we need is just
some white guys hang on the boat
incapable of that yeah but those guys
what they went to party we're white yeah
come on man we gotta get some beer you
guys are cool right
hello you sleeping dude yeah um we're
just means the other Sam we're just
talking maybe we'll just go to town just
grab a few ales then come back yeah so
like I know we're meant to watch it but
let's just grab like three ales real
close so just three and then back on it
three our cue and then right back
they'll be fine we've got like some
slaves you're watching there's sleeping
dude yeah let's go let's go
so into the into the city they go and
they left wheelman Robert smalls in
charge interesting with no white sample
I believe it's about to be pilot Robert
told the crew this was it word was sent
to Hannah and some others on shore and
on may 13th 1862 Robert and six slave
crewmen boarded the planter all except
for the guy that they didn't trust yeah
okay well I didn't even know yeah that
guy's it's it's like there's a guy in
Alcatraz Escape from Alcatraz who was
supposed to go who couldn't get out guy
couldn't fit I can fit that guy yeah
well this guy could fit yeah yeah this
guy well he couldn't fit mentally
shearing I'm saying Dave good way to put
on this right so uh so the crew agreed
if they were caught they would blow up
the ship rather than go back to slavery
Wow
so there this is a that's an attitude
that's hard to fight yep yep if the
blowing up failed they quote would all
take hands and jump overboard and perish
together okay
so they're in there's plans yeah it
seems like slavery sucks yeah they're
making a case for that yep absolutely
Robert broke into the cabin and took the
captain's straw hat and jacket and
grabbed any guns he could find and at
three
30 a.m. they sailed off the guards on
the wharf didn't do anything because the
ship was scheduled to leave right then
in the more yet usually great early I'm
gonna believe pretty okay the planter
headed to a nearby dock several blocks
north so they just go up the city a few
blocks sure stop there on another boat
is Hannah their two kids four other
women who are related to the crewmen or
whatever who and another kid also the
slave sailor brought them on that boat
okay a couple of women were girlfriends
of guys on the crew so once they're all
in the planner robber explains the plot
to all the women and stuff we just got
on the boat right some of them were
really not down with it sure one crewman
quote they didn't know much about war
but they knew enough to realize that
every man of us would be shot or hung if
the attempt was a failure they cried and
prayed and entreated and it took an hour
to calm those women down and then we
locked them in the staterooms and
threatened to kill the first one who
made a loud noise well I mean you can't
say that they didn't try soft tactics
early so so the plan was to be honest
then sort of deal with the emotional
situation they've created and when that
didn't take hold they just locked them
into like a ship shed and we're like
we'll kill the first one yeah I mean
look it went on for an hour it sounds
like I'll die no but Lord get over it I
mean get over it they don't have any
[ __ ] time to [ __ ] it's gotta be
like hey we're gonna not be slaves
anymore are you in and then you might
die that's it's the part maker but then
you make your call you're sure you're on
board or off word for sure but yeah and
now it's not long it's not long it's not
long when the next the next step in your
plan is to put them in a lock them in a
closet that's true all right all right
I'm with you now hey so the planner
heads out again has to pass five
checkpoints each one has gun batteries
to shoot at it it has to pass fight well
and what are the checkpoints like it's a
it's a it's an eyeballing yeah so I
think you're coming pretty close to
shore okay
and then there's a you know you signals
whatever flag signals or whatever sure
but you can see that you can also see
the right the person right so they can
see each other not too close but close
enough right okay so this is treacherous
for sure yeah okay so he's just as the
captain and he starts imitating the
captain's body language so he's got this
draw hat on so the distance is far
enough that you could potentially not
tell the skin colour it's also nighttime
okay right right right
okay great so he in the silhouette he
looks he's doing it mornin whitey he's
like Richard white Richard white rich
little
he's like Richard rich little of
Charleston
mornin white man it's uh he must be why
he called me a white man if you really
listen to rich little impressions
they're spectacularly bad they are all
rich little I grew up when making fun of
rich little was the bit not listening
yeah he was good oh no go back and look
I I remember recently my back and
looking I was like oh my god all rich
little questions are just rich little
that's great
what a great living he made yeah so uh
so he gives the correct signals to all
the checkpoints and they make it pass
all the checkpoint now the Sun comes up
and at that point Robert knew the
Confederates are beyond to them because
right there's no ship right so they sped
for the blockade which was a bit
problematic because the Confederate ship
was speeding at a Union blockade oh
right gotcha
right the look is like right not great
the in ship the USS onward the guy who
saw it screams and alarm they thought it
was a rebel ramming ship right the
onward was brought around to fire on the
planter and then the planter lowered the
Confederate flag and raised a white bed
sheet nice once they got close enough
Raleigh [ __ ] Gisela comfy close enough
Robert yelled out quote good
sir I've brought you some of the old
United States gun sir
that were for Fort Sumter sir days yeah
it's good intro yeah
now the 7x ship slaves the guys on the
ship cheer and then the women and kids
came up from below
everyone's hey we're gonna kill us one
by one their plan was to literally kill
any one of us are cried chained
downstairs alright alright Nancy come on
celebrate Robert turned the planter over
to the captain of the onward and the
American flag was raised on the planter
okay in the morning general Ripley wakes
up why did that boy wrap me awake
earlier
that's the R word that's how I pictured
yeah yeah so so Ripley wakes up and he's
like what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] [ __ ]
I think that's an exact quote did he say
that yeah this is beardy no mouth beardy
yeah no math Barry wakes up and he's
like what's what's happening again so no
one knows anything right everybody's
just very confused well that sounds like
the south at this time yeah the guard
had been posted the guards were posted
at the wharf yeah said no took off at
3:30 and the captain was up on the rail
yeah about the three [ __ ]
so they started looking for everybody
they're looking for the captain and the
officers and then fine they find him and
they don't know anything so what was
their their plan was to just get go to
[ __ ] you just get shit-canned and then
not do anything I think they've done it
a million times I think they had you
know just gone off got shit-faced and
then come back in the morning and slaves
they've been watching the boat and
everything's good so finally the
Confederates look out and they see the
planter right next to the ships in the
blockade and they're like oh that's the
flags different well that happened so
rumors I'm a pilot [ __ ]
Wilma Nassau that wheelman of course
rumors went around that it was white
Union spies because it couldn't be the
guys wore the skin of a black man they
pretend our theory is complex to say
it's not great to have some holes it has
a lot of holes but it it what it does is
it preserves the idea that whites are
great yes it cannot be outsmart it's the
barrier right Confederate leaders in
Richmond Virginia we're told what had
happened this is very bad news because
the planter was exactly the kind of ship
the Union needed which was a shallow
water transport ship hey I guess you
just can't have slaves for so long yeah
also tons of guns on board a little bit
of robert e lee yeah bob bobster who is
the if you're from another country he's
a monster who was the leader of the
south the Confederate Army I guess he
wasn't the leader yeah kind of not great
that's him he looks mad I picked one
where he looks mad because it just
happened I think again look at how
sloppy that stupid little tie is it's
not great Plus comb the side of your
hair yeah I mean honestly
so I mean buttons do you have okay
alright let's take it easy there was a
big button time big button a lot of
things to clasp he wanted whoever was
responsible punished Charleston
newspapers called the white officers
absence quote criminal disgusting
treachery absolutely other press in the
South jumped on board calling it quote
gross negligence and demanded prompt
punishment one newspaper called it quote
one of the most shameful events of this
or any other war absolutely aside from
enslaving of people skinner echelon
straight it's amazing what a tragedy
yeah we won't be embarrassed about this
in the future
this is so embarrassing me you guys went
to drink and left the people we owned to
just be on a ship guys guys
history will not look back fondly on the
fact that the whites let the blacks cup
seriously you guys are gonna look like
dicks oh my god dicks
one paper said the officers thought the
war was a quote nice frolic yeah not
taking it seriously sure the three white
ship officers were arrested in jailed
over in the other side you have any idea
what it's like to be put in a place you
don't want to be we're still pro-slavery
over on the other side Robert was having
a great time he told the story to the
local Commodore who told the captain of
the onward to submit a claim for the
black crew so anytime a ship was
captured by the Union
it was auctioned off and half of the
money went to the Union and then the
other half went to the crew that had
captured the ship dynamite in this case
they were they were saying the Almer
didn't capture it just give it to the
black crew yeah brought it over the
Commodore then sent a recently captured
southern civilian so they had captured a
boat and there was a civilian guy on it
and they sent him back to Charleston
with a message well this is awkward that
the Commodore found it quote mortifying
that the planter should have been
purloined from officers who he still
considered countryman pick a side
[ __ ] so so that none of this was
helping the three white officers who had
been arrested they were court-martialed
and charged with disobedience of orders
and neglect of duty two were convicted
the charges against the other guy were
dropped after a general concluded the
office so they're tried convicted
everyone's happy and then a general buts
in and said this isn't right the
officers were not given clear orders to
stay on the ship and the ship owner who
was a rich Scotsman named George
Ferguson didn't seem to care about
giving the order and never seem to give
a [ __ ] that there should be white men on
the ship at all time so they're blaming
the owner now okay so now right Ferguson
his wife had high social status in
Charleston and they owned a few ships
and the two crew officers were then
released and whites in Charleston were
livid sure I mean let me know when
they're not living
look they got a lot of beef so the - uh
so they they wanted someone punished for
letting the slaves I'm gonna have to get
over there ladies just can't go free
another very angry person in all this
was Samuel Kingman Hannah's owner uh-huh
sure so he was out he's now out for
slaves right Hanna their two kids and
her daughter Clara all of them okay so
he filed the claim for loss of property
with the state of South Carolina imagine
actually like getting that form in front
of you for a human lost probably our
name not a problem
okay good history yeah there's he's
looking good by the way
clean up the neck game so uh right so he
said Hanna was worth 800 Clara a
thousand this is after he'd made the
deal no no so he's asked for
compensation okay for losing his slaves
okay who he he blames on the obviously
the government for the [ __ ] up right
yeah so Hannah's where the 800 Claire's
a thousand cuz I guess there's a peek
she's she's a young lady so cool and
then Elizabeth's three hundred because
she's a kid and then Robert who's an
infant 150 bucks
wow what a bargain bargain Roberts owner
Henry McKee he's in a totally different
place he had already lost all of his
property when the Union captured Port
Royal he lost his homes as Landon his
slaves okay when two and then two of his
kids died from scarlet fever so he's
pretty bummed sure he's like depressed
and didn't seek any compensation for his
slave also probably a son
sure well that is one of the side
effects of depression yeah yeah you
don't want money for your kid yeah as
far as the war the planter is is huge
or in the cabin was a book with all the
quote secrets of the signals of the
Confederacy so sergeant I found a little
something in here hey in here there's a
book that has everything put it in the
maybe pile so now all the little signal
flags we talked about before they know
every signal he's just saying [ __ ] you
he keeps saying [ __ ] you over and over
also the Union learned the Confederates
had abandoned an island that was in a
very important location in Charleston
Harbor and so they just took the island
lady Island yeah no but that's yeah so
there's another Confederate Island that
they there are a few kinds of islands
yeah there's a little racist archipelago
Island South Carolina North Carolina
sure it's not such as cliffs bro silence
out there detect a license but if you
would know that with all the [ __ ]
documentaries you watch about nature
watched four hours of David Attenborough
on the plane today so you don't talk to
me about what I know about nature
[ __ ] okay do you have any idea the
the the in don't even get me started on
the tendons of kangaroos I shouldn't say
so the North goes apeshit a slave
stealing an important ship from the
Confederates right at the spot where the
war had started it was delightful you
read it back it does like it could be a
great grabbing headline so Robert smalls
escape is huge news
so Robert smalls runs out of holes to
[ __ ] the Confederates in so for the
planter they get the money he gets 1500
which is now about $37,000 could he buy
the owner how great would that no no for
you I just want you to walk around my
cocktail party without any bottoms on
and serve my friends yeah yes mr.
Small's the other criminal mr. Small's
you know Thurman got four to four
hundred fifty dollars each two
girlfriends got $100 each and the wives
didn't get any money because the married
women
quote would derive benefit through their
various relationships to the men plus
all that crime mm-hm
while the girlfriends quote have no such
connection and our destitute and
unprovided for so if your girlfriend you
get a little bit a little scratch well
let's do you mount however was actually
insanely low and was probably a praise
low because they were ex-slaves so they
actually did get kind of [ __ ]
well then like twice that sure not not
surprising yeah there's still white
people well now now we're facing slavery
yeah and racism yeah now we're now we're
hating racism head-on yeah finally would
have been funny if I just not [ __ ] that
up
Robert went to work helping to remove
underwater mines in Charleston Harbor
okay underwater mines yeah so they
underwater mines so it's a it's a it's a
it's an explosive device attached to an
anchor that just drifting in that's just
at the bottom or they're just floating
they well here's the bottom it's
weighted so then the mine goes up to the
top where a ship will hit it where you
can't see it but it's you know yeah so
ecology is really hard to pin down from
yeah yeah so they're all over Charleston
Harbor but Robert and then one of the
guys who put them down so he knew where
they all were and they use when took
them all out you know and we left our
magic book on that ship here we left our
book of spells so he's making about
forty bucks a month now she's pretty
[ __ ] good I think the average guy
made like thirteen he's rolling average
black soldiers so Robert also became a
voice in the abolition movement when he
was invited to speak in New York but
Abril Admiral DuPont so you know he's
he's he's working for the for the Union
Navy so he added the Admirals in charge
of and so this Admiral was like I don't
want you going to yeah this guy yeah he
likes to touch his pockets the inside
ones makes the robbers tell me I know
people don't like when we talk about the
pictures
you gotta see this cake could not look
like he's masturbating a belly button
more ya know that feels nice
so uh he's got a nice jacket it's a nice
feeling inside there woman um no one
tells me what to do I'm in charge so
he'll be worried Robert would be taken
advantage of if he went to New York
because the year before PT Barnum had
hired an escaped slave William Tillman
Tillman had killed three captors with an
axe and escaped so he was free old a
murderer he barred up scrape at the
bottom of the barrel now what else we
have here's a man who killed people with
an axe all right coming before we bring
up the chicken who walks backwards a
murderer so he was a free he was a free
guy who got captured by some southerners
and they were gonna make him a slave and
he killed them on the next good story I
would like that to be a show so so yeah
so PT Barnum and like put him on display
with the ax at his Museum so Admiral
DuPont didn't want this kind of thing to
happen to Robert right so I didn't say
made him keep working on the ships
Hannah and the kids went back to live in
Beaufort it'd be just as easy to just
say do not talk to PT Barnum yeah okay
continue I think that goes for everybody
yes plantations so Hannah goes and the
kids go back to live in Beaufort the
plantations that have been abandoned or
captured were being used to give newly
freed blacks places to live and work so
they're trying to turn the plantation to
something and keep this you know people
alive by giving them jobs and stuff
right Robert was a big name now
and in August 1862 he made a trip to DC
and helped persuade Lincoln to allow
black men to enlist and fight for the
Union Knight up to 5,000 black men were
allowed to join the Union forces during
the war Robert was a pilot on several
Union ships always as a civilian right
now I'll join it pilot pilot peel oh
yeah he saw action at 17 major battles
during one
the Confederates began firing on a ship
and the captain of the ship ran and hid
in the coal bunker no no no with the
coal hole where's the coal [ __ ] knows
the coal hole so now with this going on
Roberts like well I kind of don't want
to get caught again because I'll be
really yeah oh yeah and then there's a
lot of other black guys on board so he
takes over and guides the boat to safety
okay so the chief quartermaster then
made Robert captain of the planter okay
quote quote he's an excellent pilot of
undoubted slavery and in every respect
worthy of that position the present
captain is a coward though a white man
dismiss him therefore and give the
steamer to this brave black Saxon okay
so it's kind of a compliment it's a lot
of bummer just I mean it's it's it's a
it's like the it's like he read the game
like it's the right amount of negging
and the right amount of complementing
meanwhile that dudes probably still
locked in the coal like so now if
Captain Roberts making a hundred and
fifty bucks a month oh yes
and the average black soul agility it
makes 13 so he's [ __ ] killing it in
May 1863 Robert jr. died of smallpox
at age smallpox at age 16 months old so
so that's why you only charge 150 bucks
for a infant well that's your bottom
line yeah because this because now
you've just fed a baby and then it dies
yeah smallpox smallpox smallpox is
smallpox what is it airborne yeah I
don't know if smallpox ever gets out
again it's just it's it's the it's the
looks off it's horrendous yeah it looks
like you'd be like yeah goodbye now and
just jump off a building as soon as you
well thank God we haven't destroyed it I
think I was really keep it just in case
Robert and Hannah had don't worry robots
are in charge okay good
Robert and Hannah had a third child
Sarah seven months later Sarah was the
first Small's that was born a free
person okay nice I was just gonna say
the child died of smallpox but it's too
soon
so the planter was sent to Philadelphia
for an overhaul and Robert took that
time that was being repaired to learn to
read and write in 1864 so one day he's
in Philadelphia is there for a while
obviously and he gets on a streetcar and
it's a rainy day and the conductor
ordered him to move to the outer
platform which was required blacks back
then in Philadelphia it was law absorb
the rain did his stand outside in the
rain Dana outside in the rain so Robert
just got off the car he's like well that
kind of defeats the purpose yeah I know
if you know what rain is but yeah if I'm
outside then yeah it doesn't work
the purpose was genuinely was that to
make room for white people or that was
just genuinely like you're black get wet
it was just your black head outside the
street yeah hang on the outside of it
but so he walks home in the rain word
gets out it becomes this huge publicized
story they usually are person I know
right yeah yeah a union here has been
humiliated
so sentiment starts to grow to eliminate
race laws in Philadelphia which is
already a Quaker place so it's not like
that wasn't something that was being
pushed there right it's a big abolition
place abolitionist place so in
Charleston fell in the are in the in the
war
Robert was there in the plant are
helping the Union Army it's got a great
[ __ ] moment yeah just the best a few
days after the city fell Robert brought
general Saxton say brings this general
who helped take it over he brings him to
the city and there's a group of blacks
and they're cheering them on oh my god
[ __ ] you Aaron you just defeated with my
button the thing the the sort of pose of
the moment is to rub your tummy inside
of your jacket we've got so many buttons
I mean honestly that was like the
planking of the 1800s
it's like yeah Gudrun hand in your coat
and your coat what's the point I might
have a pistol so Robert brings general
Saxon into the end of the city giant
group of black you know now free people
are [ __ ] cheering and then on the
outskirts are white people not cheering
the grumblers yeah they grumblers there
was soon as the grumblers they're just
sitting there watching and then Robert
sees Ferguson the old owner owner of the
planter okay Wow
so he pushes through the crowd bringing
general Saxon with him and then he
introduces him to Ferguson oh my god
which was Robert's way of letting
Ferguson know that they're now equals
it's a pleasure to meet you Sexton hello
again I mean that's good right here's a
twenty bucks get yourself something nice
[Music]
so we'll get it back so we'll get it
back we'll get it back I'm not drunk
so Robert finds out that Mikey's house
right the one in that he grew up in okay
in and Beaufort was about to be
auctioned Oh get out of here because
what happened a lot back then was shut
up the whites would bail is this dude
about to try to buy the house that he
was a slave in so the whites would bail
right yeah because the war southern
rights to bail because that's unions
coming and then but then the moral wave
as we call it then they wouldn't pay
their property taxes sure yeah then
their house it wasn't they weren't just
taking that they were taking them
because they wouldn't pay the taxes now
right now you've lost the house because
you
so I'm interested so he G TV show he
bought the house that he grew up in as a
slave for $665 here and now lived where
he and his mother events oh my god it's
a [ __ ] kick-ass dynamite house Robert
and Hannah hosted friends and family in
the large house they were still close
with a lot of the slaves they'd escaped
with on the planter and in April 1865
the Confederacy surrendered boy that is
a crazy turn around though that has to
be one of those living in the house
minding owning but also it's not even
like I bought my childhood home that my
mother sold cuz I mean it's like you
probably couldn't fathom the reality of
a time when you would be free yeah let
alone on the farm buying the house that
took your life away no this is this is
this is the this is the biggest dream
come true moment that has ever happened
on this podcast yeah ever okay except
for the guy who called his own lightning
shot I just want to be killed by
lightning I'll never get over that
so Confederacy surrenders the south is
in ruins just [ __ ] really [ __ ] up
well it got thank God for the comeback
so that's Charleston well so yeah it's
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] so Robert helped
Henry Mackey's family inviting Henry's
Widow and some of her children to live
at his home her former home but now
they'll flip flipped a little bit cuz
she's in she and I make a pitch that he
makes them wait on them and maybe live
in a separate house have you heard of
the show it's complicated too yeah
there's a crazy dude she absolutely
complicated too Robert now bought the
house that he were here to do now the
lady who live in Italy where everywhere
Robert rent is heaven into
real complicated - it's also complex oh
[ __ ] so so now it's not all that great
because the Maki's still refuse to eat
with Robert which Robert totally
accepted just arrange for their meals to
happen at a different table not okay on
any level or any part of this I know
right he's the night you eat with him
you you [ __ ] me with you serve him
yeah you sets right you have bring the
[ __ ] food to the technically Robert
was that good right
like the craziness but the craziness of
this time then he's like alright just
yeah yeah it's like we'll have separate
eating times I mean there is there is a
huge part of this that that so blacks
are now free and they've been slaves
forever and whites are angry so there is
definitely like let's just keep this
cool yeah kind of thing like let's not
have kick off again yeah right so a few
years later Robert helped Henry Maki's
widowed daughter when she needed money
and he also helped her teenage son get
into the u.s. Naval Academy so he's just
a [ __ ] good dude in the spring of 1866
Robert was [ __ ] or transporting some
union officers when he noticed a ship
approaching from behind and was coming
very very fast it was the fanny on by
John Ferguson and I remember John
Ferguson is Scottish and he is named a
ship the fanny yeah put that out there
let's just put that [ __ ] out there find
a first let's cool yeah real weirdo
right so he's the guy used to own the
planner now this ship the Fanny is
piloted by a guy named McNulty not from
the wire thank god he's drunk
so the Fanny's coming up quickly and
then it pulls right alongside the
planner which is a super aggressive move
yeah
stoplight and McNulty then ordered the
Fanny to turn port which would put it
right in the path of the planter okay so
Robert realized what Nicole D what
McNulty was doing which was with trying
to force the planter to crash
some obstructions that were in the river
that he knew about he's watching this
from he's on he's on the planner he's on
the planner okay so that dude is [ __ ]
rolling up beside him and now trying to
push him into some [ __ ] [ __ ] that's a
river that he knows is there so so he's
like with not do that and he's Robert
speeds up and then just plows into the
fanny and pushes the [ __ ] up the
Savannah River for a half a mile how
about that [ __ ] you're supposed to go
into the debris hey bastard that's twice
he's done that that's two times so
McNulty is furious number one because he
got pushed up the river like a ship
[ __ ] yeah
and then he also got ship they also had
a black man and not back down Yeah right
Ferguson has to just be like you bastard
so McNulty pulls out a revolver and
points it at Robert and Robert grabs his
double-barrel shotgun and pointed in
McNulty and it says quote now shoot and
mind you don't miss because I won't so
he's also gotten [ __ ] little dirty
area yeah Dirty Harry action Union
offers ordered McDonald McNulty to stand
down
sure and after a while he did and then
McNulty was arrested well I'll tell you
who looks really good in this as McNulty
I'm done like a real winner in this one
[Laughter]
so the planter was sold after a little
while for the auction and off now
because the war is over they don't
really need it anymore it's valued at
$15,000
Ferguson puts in an offer
a bid of 25,000 but he is representative
to do it because he thought that if the
Union found out about his Confederate
background and he's down the ship they
wouldn't let him buy it so he has
another guy put up the bid but the
government found out and they didn't let
him buy the ship so I mean this guy
continues to win
so then the planter was sold for 7702
man at a Baltimore auction and that guy
turned out to have been a wealthy ship
owner from Charleston before the war
government had no idea and then he just
gave the planter to John Ferguson okay
great so that [ __ ] dick one yeah
did he win no I don't think you want
what you know no I mean he won that what
he's able to do now is pretend he won
with a story but I'll tell you got the
last little off me I've got the plan
tonight so name think he's on top bloody
smalls Fergie baby
Fergie so what's on top [ __ ] at like ever
to save everybody other ones now hmm
anyone please deal so Robert also became
a very successful businessman he's also
got a great mind for business he bought
property around Beaufort he co-founded
the enterprise railroad company of
Charleston he owned a store he started a
school for black children and became an
advocate for free public education he
continued to improve his own reading and
writing skills and he started a
newspaper
so he's killing it he's [ __ ] killing
it yeah yeah Robert helped form the
first Republican organization in South
Carolina and began to be called the king
of Beaufort County okay he started a
Republican organization obviously these
are different times yeah this is when
the Republicans were yeah he was
respected and switcharoo
yeah old switcharoo he was respected and
loved by the black community in the area
he was elected to the South Carolina
House of Representatives then to the
state Senate
oh yeah Wow in Beaufort
african-americans outnumbered whites 7
to 1 yes yes he was then elected to
Congress as one of the first African
American members and served in the US
House for five term starting at 18 say
wow but not not maybe in a row all this
all this all this success did not mean
he wasn't in danger South Carolina had
their own version of the Ku Klux Klan
which they were called the red shirt
there they are
a bunch of [ __ ] sheds oh yeah no that
looks like a high IQ grip which why even
face them for the camera picture again
me put red shirt on I wish we could
afford enough bugs done button a couple
put our hands inside our cutter I put a
red shirt on hey hey yeah we heard you
we already have them on look at the
camera I put a red shirt on the guy says
put a red shirt on hey we're the red
shirt shut up [ __ ]
you might be too dumb for us ah yeah
maybe not now you're saying hi we're the
red shirts yeah alright you're back note
say we're the red shirts because we've
already established that so we're not
say we are the red shirts we are not
going to say that again we have red on
top not our heads
torso okay no no body areas but you are
saving a little more shrewd than I'd
anticipated pretty well that's wiggled
so while he was touring the state with
the Republican governor in 1876 on a
campaign Robert was at a rally in
Edgefield South Carolina and a red shirt
leader and former Confederate General
over ran the rally and threatened
Roberts life and the Republicans escaped
unharmed but it was noted how easily the
red shirts had moved through the town
quote even in Mexico general Butler's
command could only be regarded as a
revolutionary army but in South Carolina
they are called reformers right today no
Robert was running an eighth in 1876
against George Tillman who was what I
would describe as one hell of a racist
great like one of the best like a
top-notch racist sure like you yeah
thank you I've always wanted to be in
company like I think we only have
do we have a picture of him it's not oh
there is we only have a drawing I'm
sorry so let's click further oh boy this
guy that's quite a drawing yeah so we're
gonna draw a guy maybe give a little
less forehead I think they were like
let's make him a dick
okay so Robert described him as quote
the arch enemy of my race so that's a
hell of a campaign
mm-hmm Tillman did everything he could
to stop Republicans from voting
including redshirt attacks but Roberts
still won the election Robert called
election day in South Carolina quote a
carnival of bloodshed and violence
that's coming both sides both sides well
they called them names before they shot
any sides the racist Democrats were not
done the democratic state the government
charged Robert with taking a $5,000
bribe he was convicted and sentenced to
three years Republicans were furious
saying he was imprisoned for being a
successful black man and Robert was
released when he appealed to the state
Supreme Court okay and then the election
of 1878 wasn't great for black
politicians in South Carolina there were
deadly threats from the white
supremacist controlled government one
observer wrote quote men are shot at
hounded down trapped and held oh god
that's a autocorrection whatever it held
certain certain meetings are over and
intimidated in every possible way
Tillman was his opponent again and this
time he managed to use Roberts
unresolved conviction to win the number
of blacks who were brave enough to face
the violence and threats to vote were
just not enough and Tillman won in a
landslide so he went from winning like
60% when he ran legitimately against him
to I think it 30% quite a drama because
of the whole will kill you thing yeah oh
and your fake conviction yeah the man
who had previously owned Roberts home
sued him so after after McKee was lost
another guy bought it I think he bought
it from a key after
like right before the invasion okay and
then that guy lost it by not paying
taxes on it say that guy is now back in
the picture
cool he's like hey man where's my house
what that was years ago I want it
he said the sale was invalid like you
can't sell my property because he
invaded because I fled it yeah but now
you can because you can still pay taxes
this was a common scenario in the south
at this point the case for Roberts house
went all the way to the US Supreme Court
in 1878 again and it upheld Roberts
title okay Robert smalls case
established a precedent across the south
for other black property owners good so
he's like [ __ ] killing it yeah all
sides yeah his bribery case was appealed
all the way to the US Supreme Court does
he have a room there now two months but
before it was heard he was pardoned by
South Carolina's Democratic governor
because he had made a deal the deal was
if he pardoned Robert the federal
government would drop election fraud
charges against a group of white
residents of South Carolina but now
Robert was upset because he was not
allowed to clear his name which would
clearly yeah also the reason he made a
deal when I went to the u.s. from court
is because he was gonna [ __ ] lose
yeah somehow Robert remained remained
optimistic believed in the election and
cheating was so quote barefaced and open
that it cannot be denied so he thinks
there's so much cheating and so much
[ __ ] dickery going on that people
gonna be like well that can't happen he
doesn't know what country he's living in
it turns out that never works now will
yawn and move on but he lost the
election
the next election to tilman again and as
the republican party fell apart due to
corruption he contested the election on
the grounds tilman and the red shirts
had used violence to intimidate voters
the US congress agreed agreed with
smalls yeah okay and he was seated Wow
yeah yes the Democrats like they didn't
take part in the vote thinking that if
they weren't there there wouldn't be a
quorum and they wouldn't be able to do
it but they did they were had enough
votes so they've always been idiots now
the South Carolina state Democrats
responded by gerrymandering the state so
no blacks could win a seat anywhere
still Robert was Robert and as luck
would have it a candidate died just
before the 1884 election and he was
elected can't beat me so in the next
election he faced a new opponent he was
now up against African American Henry
Thompson who is trying to capitalize on
the growing rifts between light and dark
skinned African Americans and what is he
he was dark skinned and remember Roberts
light-skinned yeah so he is now saying
Robert is not an authentic black yeah
basically I mean isn't it great how it
has to come down to this but yeah so
he's saying Robert is that it's that guy
I'm trying to find an older picture of
him but I yeah that's him that's Robert
smalls okay so I think we can agree
pocket watches we're still in like it's
not a very good picture that guy at some
point you just got tired and blinked you
what do you have to wait like a minute
nine hours so the infighting between the
light-skinned and the lost that lost in
the election the infighting caused the
Democrats to win and Robert smalls lost
Hannah died suddenly in 1883 Robert
married again seven years later in 1890
made a lady and then they had a son she
is okay yeah then she died okay like
three five years after they got married
Robert Robert made sure all of his kids
were educated even though he served
during the war as a civilian in 1897 he
was granted a military pension of $30 a
month okay he was appointed as the u.s.
customs collector for the port of
Beaufort by president Benjamin Harrison
in 1889 and he kept the job until 1892
when he was kicked to the curb during
the Cleveland administration he was then
reappointed by the Republican William
McKinley in 1898 okay he served until
1912 when his reappointment by President
Taft was blocked I'm not gonna do it by
two white senators one was named
Benjamin Tillman humbly who was the
brother of George Tillman Oh what's who
is the most evil looking racist that has
ever been something he gets his own
podcast third nostril and missing an eye
yes so you just got an extra nose hole
and no I hope Wow that is definitely
evil well what happened was he actually
had he had so he had to they're called
technically medically they're called
nose hole plugs uh-huh and he sucked one
up and it popped out his eye oh okay
that's what happened to him actually
looks like what happens when you just
suck on a milkshake too hard you got an
F third nostril and your eye goes so
Robert died of complications from
diabetes in his what it's a de beedis
what does he call it on the guy from
cocoon the guy from cocoon Wilford
Brimley Oh diabetes diabeetus no what
does it call diabetes
Robert died from diabetes in his home in
Beaufort on February 23rd 1915 the
monument where he is buried is engraved
with this quote from a speech he made to
the South Carolina legislature in 1895
quote my race needs no special defense
for the past history of them and this
country proves them to be the equal of
any people anywhere all they need is an
equal chance in the Battle of life by
what a great if they got it at some
point his house is designated a National
Historic Landmark there's currently a
proposal to erect a monument in his
memory on the grounds of the South
Carolina State House no black
representative had such a long
congressional tenure as Robert smalls
until the 1950s yeah what do I think
well I think that our history was
slavery doesn't ever seem to get better
but it is good I mean it is good to like
yeah it was good to hear I mean you know
look it is just nice when you hear
stories about people getting sticks
rammed up their ass and like this like
Ferguson and all these guys like that
took a weird turn why what what when
when evil people get screwed yeah it
feels good even though overall it's
terrible and you know it's like you do
need even yeah we just need to enjoy the
small victories yeah yeah I think that
you really have to enjoy the victories
of someone who is awful suffering yeah
and you also need I mean we're going to
need the knowledge and the strength to
remind ourselves that you need to take
action at some point to stop [ __ ]
yeah and it's going to be different for
white people because they don't have a
real strong relationship with doing
stuff yeah well they do stuff they just
don't do it there
that's called not doing it right it's
not doing stuff but what does that say
canary then it's the Wi-Fi pen that's
the password
okay it's real small yeah I don't know I
mean it's I'm glad I know about this
dude yeah no he's going then look rarely
do we do a podcast about a guy who was a
hero
yeah there's a yeah genuine badass
[ __ ] hero wants to love yeah yeah
scheisse on your car then we get out of
here yeah that's a good sign
all right thanks everybody Aaron you're
fired Aaron's fired sorry about that but
good work though not sure where you're
gone